now Colin stammering is chief exactly of
the London Chamber of Commerce and
Industry so Colin the Federation for
small businesses has put a figure on the
the cost of this dispute at 300 million
pounds do you recognize that yes it
sounds like a bit of a philosophy I
don't recognize that that that figure
it's certainly the case that it runs
into tens of millions it's been a mug's
game trying to predict you know what
those cost is because if you think about
you know what's the sector that's been
most hit today probably Oxford Street
Regent Street you know that the shopping
street well you could put a figure on
the lost sales there but who knows
whether those lost sales are going to be
you know recouped later in the week when
there isn't a strike but there's no
doubt tens of millions of pounds just in
terms of lost productivity people being
late and not to mention people's
demeanor I've just walked across a
bridge to get here in the rain through
the crowds as they queue to get on a bus
or queue to get into a tube station you
know the ones that that are open and
there are a couple other there are quite
a number open and you just think the
effect is having on them and you know
their attitude towards work and how long
do they really want to make that sort of
journey if there was an alternative yes
yes the good news is that this isn't at
the height of the tourist season there
aren't too many tourists around well the
problem is is is that you know I might
expected quite a lot of television
interviews today about this and I
suspect not me necessarily but the
pictures of what we've just seen on your
program will be going round the world
and if you were a tourist you might be
thinking oh gosh I didn't realize London
was like that I think for us as a
business organization as the Chamber of
Commerce you're our fear is that as we
sort of come to terms of brexit and
there's no doubt you know London
companies will make the best of brixon
even if though you know they voted 6040
let's bring you know pretty hefty
majority to stay in the EU so they're
coming to terms of that but they'll make
up the fist of it we still need to fight
you know as the uncertainty continues as
you know people think about making
investments decisions from India from
America or whatever it is to keep our
place as a world City a place where you
want to set up your your business and I
think that having that sort of message
going around and we've had the southern
rail go on for the weeks months what
appears and this on top of that I think
it's just a terrible time a terrible
time for that message did we go across
the world
well now somehow isn't open for business
when our slogan is you know now you've
met the role ministers today to discuss
the southern dispute down what have you
heard there from the government today do
you think that unions are coordinating
all this this try-catch well the
government says that they're doing and
we were delighted the Romanist have
found the time to see us and on a day
like this and they tell us that the real
ministers told us and i believe him that
they're doing all they can of course
it's a really between a company and and
the union so they are they are hampered
in in that way but they say that they
are trying to do all that they can to to
solve this situation my fear is that it
becomes and that i don't be overdramatic
about this but it becomes a sort of tory
parties - strike that you know somehow
whether people are on the Union side are
trying to make it into some sort of
winter of discontent or or take on the
government that will find ourselves in
entrenched positions where no side can
back over so actually the dispute which
is said to be about safety said to be
our opening doors and automation of
trays turns into a political dispute and
then it's the pool it's the poor
business the pools
yeah but it's enough of the real
minister to just say we're doing all we
can or me did he not give you any sort
of concrete actions well he did get was
another number of concrete things that
they that they were trying to do and I
think the message that came from them is
that they didn't feel the union's wanted
to talk to them even when money was on
was on the table really so so a case
right lawyering strike action on public
transport I have said all along in this
job that you know people have a right to
strike I would be very much against the
idea of of of withdrawing that right to
strike however with Rights come
responsibilities and if it does turn out
and I have no idea whether this case but
if it really did turn out that somehow
this was a political strife in behalf of
as little or they are empty I think
people like me will start to think again
about whether you know you earn that
right to strike and whether you can keep
that right destroyed